[Music]
The Legend of Zelda tears of the Kingdom
may have the highest expectations put on
any Nintendo game in recent years not
only is it the latest release in the
storied Zelda franchise it's also a
direct sequel to breath of the wild
regarded by Vinnie to be one of the best
games of all time recent trailers have
revealed an emphasis on building
incredible machines with a new suite of
tools a seeming nod to the network of
Zelda fans who have pulled off amazing
feats in breath of the wild and while
Nintendo is still maintaining the
mystery around much of the game our
extensive Hands-On with the new tools
showed an incredible amount of creative
problem solving and thrilling traversal
in this ambitious sequel
my Hands-On demonstration was composed
of two parts first I began with a short
segment on the ground with a simple
objective of getting past some enemies
and into a tower this was mostly just
for the sake of testing the waters with
the array of new tools before preparing
to dive into the deep end while the most
obvious path was to go up a ramp
structure through a handful of enemies
there were much easier ways and while
there were strict limitations on where I
could go during the demo session there
were almost no restrictions on what I
could do within the spaces provided my
first approach was the straightforward
one stride into the enemy base with my
sword and challenge enemies to combat
this was destined to fail and I knew it
not least because I'm severely out of
practice in breath of the Wild's combat
but I thought it was worthwhile to try
regardless I was handling myself fine
against a boca blind but his nearby
moblin friend took notice of the scuffle
and came to help and I was caught off
guard that was the end of that life for
my second attempt I decided to use the
new building tools to circumvent the
enemies altogether the ultra hand
ability the new Marquee building tool
that lets you create complex structures
and machines can grab just about
anything that isn't connected to the
ground but I didn't happen to have any
fly flying implements around me rather
than needing to build everything from
scratch each time there is a streamlined
option for building with ultra hand so
for the sake of expediency and getting
to know the tools I used that to build a
small simple but functional hot air
balloon a dragon-headed machine part
faced upward into the balloon and
breathed fire when struck taking on a
straight vertical Ascent once I had
gained enough height over the enemy base
I simply hopped off the balloon and hang
glided away past them to the goal
[Music]
then I was ushered into the second much
more expansive part of the Hands-On demo
this one took place in the sky islands
with more open-ended goals and a massive
amount of space to explore I was given
an objective try to Island hop your way
over to a distant floating landmass and
very few limitations I wasn't allowed to
dive back to the ground and a few select
Islands were off limits but other than
that I was just given some tools and
told to explore the same streamlined
building tool was still available and I
also had access to a zonai parts
distributor that Nintendo cheerfully
nicknamed the gumball machine
[Music]
it's easy to see why as
a candy dispenser you insert some cores
and you get a random assortment of zonai
machine components in return the ultra
hand can stick together anything from
the world like felled trees or rocks
along with any of the machine like zunai
Parts those include fans the
aforementioned fire breathing dragon
head machine a piston that launches
objects or you on a regular rhythm and
most entertainingly Rockets they look
and act exactly like rockets which
includes launching you into the
atmosphere with massive propulsive Force
there's also a control yoke Zona part
which not only lets you steer vehicles
but also activates whatever engine type
you've attached automatically the ultra
hand is remarkably easy to use once you
get used to it you can stick Parts
together in just about any configuration
you can imagine and the tool lets you
snap to certain angle degrees since it's
all physics based symmetry equals
stability the game understands this and
gives you a little help locking for
example a second rocket at the same
ankle as you place the first it only
took a few minutes of toying with the
feature before I felt like I completely
understood how to use it and while my
designs weren't anything too impressive
they were often perfectly functional
with minimal control fussing sometimes
the island hopping solution was obvious
a couple of fans and a flat surface can
obviously be put together to make a
floating platform and reach new heights
for example other times I would need to
summon an airplane designed to cross a
longer stretch of ground each time I
made a little progress I was encouraged
to use the travel Medallion to mark my
progress this handy returning feature
lets you make a one-time fast travel
Point anywhere in the Overworld and you
can recall it remotely to make a new one
this is especially useful for challenges
like the one I was presented with to
cross several islands since I could mark
my progress as I went
by far my favorite moment of the demo
though came from seeing how these tools
could be used to solve puzzles while I
enjoyed breath of the wild in its
sandbox model I missed the Clockwork
Precision of the classic Zelda puzzles
and their intricately tailored Solutions
I enjoy the feeling of finding the
correct answer which is slightly
different than simply finding a clever
way to exploit a physics system to my
surprise tears of the Kingdom bridged
that Gap by presenting open-ended
physics-based puzzles but with solutions
that felt so intuitive I still got the
satisfaction of finding my own
complicated but correct way at one point
I had to cross a wide Chasm to another
Island on my left side with a large
structure as the pivot point between the
two islands I could move the structure
by manipulating and turning a small
model of it with my ultra hand I found I
could turn the structure so that a
bridge extended to me which would let me
cross the structure itself but then
there was no way to get from there to
the other island or I could turn the
bridge towards the structure but
couldn't get to it either way I was
stuck and my glider wasn't enough to
cross the chasm I needed to figure out
how to cross onto the structure then
move it to serve as a bridge to the next
Island after some tinkering my solution
was to make use of the new recall
ability which rewinds objects to a prior
State I move the structure into position
as a bridge to the second island then
moved it back to me me on the first
island I started to cross then hit it
with recall rewinding time so that it
would move backwards and become a moving
platform I felt very clever for this but
at the moment it simply felt like the
right way to solve the puzzle I needed a
moving platform so I made one it was
only afterward that a Nintendo rep told
me I could have simply flipped the
entire structure upside down and it
would have just made a normal Bridge or
I realized I could have moved it into
either of the positions and used a hot
air balloon to gain some height so I
could Glide over I didn't actually have
to MacGyver my way into making it a
moving platform at all but I
instinctively read that as the goal and
the tools were flexible enough to let me
solve it that way I had a similar
experience building my own aircraft to
cross the final Chasm to my goal there
was a metallic structure with a divot
that served as a resting place for one
of the plane Parts which had a fin that
slotted in perfectly to act as a Runway
I placed two fans atop the plane then
another identity plane piece on top for
a sort of zonai version of the Wright
brothers biplane I place the control
yoke on top but it occurred to me that
the lower deck would have been a good
way to transport items across large
distances how long that distance can be
though is an open question the zonai
machines appeared with battery icons
like the one on your cell phone for the
purposes of the demo I had three large
bars of battery which was plated across
the gaps needed for our island hopping
Excursion but I was also pre-equipped
with a very full stamina bar for
climbing so Nintendo was definitely
giving the press a leg up in that regard
I suspect that like stamina you'll
progressively unlock more battery power
for your Zona devices if that's the case
it's hard to say just how far you'll be
able to go when the game begins and
whether you can ultimately build your
way up to vehicles that can cross the
entire map upon reaching my goal I still
had a few minutes left and decided to
devote them to searching the large
island for combat encounters so I could
experiment with the new fuse and other
abilities views will be mostly
associated with combat but it has
applications for exploring the world too
fusing a sword with a rock certainly
looks funny and it makes your web been
more powerful and more durable but the
new DIY Sledgehammer can also break open
cracked walls and Floors I have to
imagine there will be more applications
of the fuse ability itself unlocking
secret Areas combat is as engaging as
you would expect from a sequel to breath
of the wild but the fuse ability adds a
new dimension of experimentation a quick
menu option lets you fuse items from
your inventory to your currently
equipped weapon which I found slightly
difficult to get a hang of In the Heat
of combat with an enemy bearing down on
me I also had to remember for example to
switch to my bow before hitting the
quick menu to try fusing something with
an arrow which led to more than a few
mistakes on my part there's definitely a
learning curve which feels like it'll
make mastering combat and fusing on the
Fly that much more rewarding
thank you that said even mistakes are
enjoyable like the ultra hand fuses a
massive toy box and you're encouraged to
try different combinations just to see
what happens I tried attaching a bomb to
a sword to see if hitting something it
would just blow me up and sure enough
yes I attached a Keith's eyeball to a
stick to see if it would heat seek like
The Arrow if I threw it no luck I was
told later that attaching a wing to a
weapon does however give it more air
time like the ultra hand building tools
the sheer number of different possible
combinations and applications for fuse
is mind-boggling I was hopelessly
outmatched however as the nearest enemy
was a massive golem-like creature even
my best attacks barely dented it and
like my earlier encounter with the
moblin I was too out of practice to stay
in a chance with the oddso Stacked
against me but as the old saying goes if
at first you don't succeed go back with
a bomb sword and blow yourself up I
didn't win but I was grinning the entire
time while the demo showed the mass of
scope and versatility in just a few
small areas it feels like I've barely
scratched the surface My Demo included
absolutely no story content and I'm no
closer to answering the question of
whether tears of the Kingdom will
include more traditional Zelda dungeons
there's a lot of mystery left to uncover
even after receiving a much better sense
of the new building tools that mystery
like the brain bending amount of
customization and creativity that'll
surely extend from these tools will be
something the players will have to
explore together when the game Launches
on May 12th starting then just like the
first game and perhaps even more so the
community of Zelda fans will get to
plumb its depths together tears of the
Kingdom looks to be Nintendo inspired by
his own fans creativity and next month
that cycle will start all over again
[Music]
thank you